When we're talking about
performance, doing less work
is important.
But sometimes when
you do work is just
as important as how
much work you do.
I'm Ian Ni-Lewis.
Smart devices have plenty of
ways to drain your battery.
The CPU, the radios, and
all the various sensors
need a lot of power to operate.
Now, if all of these systems
were powered up all the time,
there's no way our
devices could last
a full day on a battery small
enough to fit into your pocket.
So to conserve power, each
of the systems in the device
is designed to go to sleep
when it's not needed.
But most of these
components have power states
that are a little more
sophisticated than just
sleeping and waking.
And just like me in the
morning, individual components
in a smart device take some time
to wake up from a deep sleep.
And not only time,
but also energy.
Oscillating between being all
the way asleep and all the way
awake can consume nearly as
much power as just staying awake
all the time.
And to avoid this,
manufacturers design each system
with multiple power
states, from fully off,
through one or more stages of
readiness, to fully powered.
For instance, a WCDMA radio
has four power states.
Each successive state
consumes more power,
but the higher the power state,
the more quickly the device
can become fully operational.
Now, this kind of
design works really well
when the load on the
device is bursty.
That is, a bunch of
work items arrive
fairly close to one
another, and then
there's a long period
where no items arrive.
So during a burst,
the radio will maybe
oscillate a bit between
its top power modes,
but it never gets into
a state where it would
take a long time to wake up.
And then when the
work tails off,
it drops to a lower power
mode, then a lower one,
and finally down to its
deepest level of sleep.
But what if the load
doesn't follow this pattern?
Well, if work items are
spaced out a bit more,
then the radio spends more
time in high power states,
even though it doesn't spend
any more time doing real work.
The worst case scenario
is that work items
arrive at just the
right frequency
to keep the radio
from ever going idle.
And this is exactly what
happens, for example,
when a device is running a large
number of apps that are all
doing background syncs
on their own slightly
different schedule.
If you want to avoid being
that app that wastes power,
you need to find a way
to do your background
work at the same
time as other apps
so you can share the cost of
these power state transitions.
But how do you do that?
Well, fortunately Android
gives you several options
for scheduling your
background work
to run in a batch with
work from other processes.
Let's start with the simplest
technique, Alarm Manager.
Now, Alarm Manager is
like an alarm clock.
It schedules a wake-up
call for your app.
You can ask for an inexact
alarm or an exact alarm.
If you use an exact
alarm, the system
will try to wake up your app at
exactly the time you asked for.
The problem with that
is that you might not
be waking up at a time that's
convenient for the device.
So if you ask for an
inexact alarm instead,
you're giving the permission
to adjust your time slightly
to align it with
an existing batch.
So how do you get
that inexact behavior?
Well, if you want
a one-shot alarm,
you call AlarmManager.setWindow.
And if you want a
repeating alarm,
you call AlarmManager.set
InexactRepeating.
Now, both of those calls
create inexact alarms.
Now, don't call
AlarmManager.setExact
unless you absolutely have to.
For instance, if your app
really is an alarm clock.
A more comprehensive technique
is to implement a sync adapter
in your app.
Now, sync adapters give you
exactly the same batching
behavior as inexact
alarms, but they also
give you network
connectivity checks
and automatically retries.
Implementing a sync adapter can
be a little daunting at first
because they're composed of
a number of moving parts.
Don't get discouraged.
There is an online training
guide that will help you get up
and running fast.
Finally, if you're
targeting API 21 or higher,
you get the best of both worlds.
The new job scheduler
API, it's as easy
to use as Alarm Manager,
but it gives you
all of the important features
of sync adapter and more.
You can specify the schedule,
the amount that the system is
allowed to deviate from that
schedule, and a whole set
of conditions the define when
the job should and shouldn't
run.
For instance, with
one line of code,
you can set up a job that
will run periodically,
but only when the
device is charging
and only when it's on Wi-Fi.
You can even set up a retry
with backup [? policy ?] in case
the job fails.
Now, that's all done
through JobInfo.Builder.
So stop wasting power.
Batching your background
jobs is incredibly easy.
It might be the
easiest battery saving
technique you'll ever learn.
Now, there's plenty
more power saving tips
on the Android Performance
Patterns home page,
so check it out.
And don't forget
to join G+ group.
And remember, keep calm.
Profile your code.
And as always, perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]